[Music]
these are all objects that were created
on 3d printers and there are different
types of 3d printers you'll see most of
these objects are white using a hard ABS
plastic others will have multiple colors
and then others can even do different
materials some 3d printers will even do
metal titanium so there are a lot of
medical applications like an artificial
hip which is very custom-made for an
individual can be 3d printed out of
titanium the way it works is it starts
with a plate and then layer by layer a
very very thin layer at a time it builds
up this model and you can see down here
there's this darker material which is
called the support material and then the
actual model material and so the support
material is used anywhere that is
required to provide a little bit of
structure and then you dump this into a
lightweight acid bath and it dissolves
the support material and you're left
with just the finished product many of
these pieces are really intricate and
very kinetic so this piece was created
in a single pass in the 3d printer it's
not put together link by link and again
the way that was done is with the
support material filling in the gaps and
then you drop it into the bath and the
support material dissolves and you end
up with something like this
or like this so working shock absorber
spring or even something with with gears
on it we're seeing this type of 3d
printing being used for rapid
prototyping by major companies by small
design firms and even by individuals so
we're seeing a trend of consumers
creating things and being able to submit
them to services on the web where they
could have a rapid prototype sent to
them or even a finished manufactured
product sent to them